let's pick up on our caller from the
three one zero area code who's calling
today from three one zero hey Preston on
speaker love you Shirley
no no I just took about so I I feel that
politics is not meant to help the
average American I feel like there's too
much mall too much money that is running
things in the country is it ever a
possibility that money gets taken out of
politics only if people who benefit from
money being in politics decide they want
to get it out and this is the
fundamental conflict we're always up
against the people who are in power got
in power with the system we have it's
hard to get into power if you don't have
the money because everybody else is
taking the money so what you eventually
end up with is you're relying on people
who benefited from the money being in
politics to take it out and that's
always a difficult thing because once
people have power they are not typically
inclined to change the system that got
them there so yes money could be removed
there's a few different ways that it
could do it it could be done the fastest
way to do it depends on who you ask and
what the political climate is who's in
the Supreme Court there's a very good
chance that any serious challenge to
money in politics would end up or some
element of it would get end up going
through the Supreme Court if Trump gets
re-elected and the Supreme Court goes
7-2 with Trump replacing Ginsburg with a
conservative justice that is a massive
obstacle to getting money out of
politics so we've got to think
systemically about this stuff but yeah
unless money is out of politics there
it's the the status quo perpetuates
money in politics and money in politics
perpetuates the status quo thank you all
right thank you for calling in I
appreciate your call your phone call I
apologize I'm not able to take any more
calls today I do see we've got 40 or so
people holding but I did the best I
could we will take more calls again
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this